i saw this article earlier christy
you saw it too and and you know we both
said let's have a conversation about
this because you're married i'm single
so we can we can really have a real good
conversation with this because i
i have some questions to a married
person that had my own perspective this
kind of wrote me wrong and i was like
what what
what in the world yeah uh but this
article was on cnbc
this article has the nerve to say has
the nerve
people to say it's absolutely critical
to have a separate bank account when you
are married
even when you're married don't rely on a
joint bank account says best-selling
author
of smart women finish rich and
co-founder of a
e wealth management david boch what
you should have your own account both of
you tell cnbc
make it uh make it make it adding it's
absolutely critical especially for women
that you keep money in an account that's
yours and that you control after all
nearly
half of marriages end wow
he says and is almost uh always the
woman
that is hurt the most financially in
divorce so
i want you to have your own investment
account i want you to have your own
emergency account
i want you to have your own credit cards
and your and your own credit score
what in the world then you can also
maintain a joint account
or what he calls the we account in which
you can
together stash money to pay for your
rent utilities bills
all that type of stuff but he's pretty
much saying in this
ridiculous article that
if you are married if you come together
as one
stay divided when it comes to your
finances yeah you know what was
interesting about that last thing that
you just said uh we could we
you could also maintain a joint account
like an afterthought
your joint account is the afterthought
or what we call a wii account you know
what i hear in that and this is this is
what bugs me about the whole thing
anthony it's not even really about the
accounts honestly it's not about the
money or
that part is a is a byproduct of it it's
the premise of the whole
perspective that sometimes we're a team
and sometimes we're not
yes we're going to sometimes act like a
team in this area of our life but we're
going to sometimes
not and you know what as a believer as a
just in general at someone that values
marriage and what that means to make a
commitment to someone when you
take vows when you walk down the aisle
you're making a commitment to that
person to be a team now
do half of marriages in a divorce yeah
that's really unfortunate but it doesn't
mean that while you're married you
shouldn't act like a team when you can
while you can
to be a team you know i use this example
with you and i want to know your
thoughts on this
so my husband um you know we're we we're
big sports people he loves basketball i
love football we love watching sports
you know
back when we used to have sports but he
would say sometimes you'd see a pattern
with football players this may happen in
basketball too but especially football
players where when they would get that
they play really hard the year that
their contract is up you know
because they want to get a really good
deal get a really good contract and then
after they sign this big deal
they get comfortable yeah they kind of
take their foot off the gas they kind of
don't play as hard
and you know what you see is you see the
whole team suffer
because this person had their own agenda
this person was trying to do their own
thing
and i think you know you asked me as a
married person i'll tell you matt and i
have been married
eight years and we've had three kids in
that time
and you go through some really difficult
thing things you could have never
imagined
it's not just uh a good idea to be a
team it's essential
yes to be a team and i think this is
just that's what bugs me is because this
acts like being a team is optional and i
don't think it is
yeah here's my problem as a single
person that doesn't make me
want to get married i'm just being
honest if everything is still about
i and and the only thing that is we
is when it's time to pay bills but you
go make your money
you do what you want to do with your
money i make my money i do what i want
to do with my money and then we just all
with our money separate money we just
put a little bit in the pot to pay bills
so we can live but i'm over here
spending money over here you're over
here doing what you want to do where
where is the wheat and i think the
problem that i have with this article
is that it's out there that they are
saying 50
of the people who get married are
divorced
well my prayer is that i'm on the
opposite side and so i'm going to go in
thinking that we're not going to get
divorced that's right i'm going to go in
there thinking
that we are going to build wealth
not just we pay bills yeah and it makes
me think of that example i may quote
this wrong but
uh dave has used this example at andre
leadership event so that the clydesdale
horses you know they're they're working
horses that can pull an unbelievable
amount of weight i want to say if i'm
going by memory here
that one clydesdale can pull around 12
000
pounds so you would think that when you
put two together that they would pull
twenty four thousand but they can't they
pull
forty eight thousand yes when you put
them together i had a friend uh this was
years ago but she came to me kind of for
money advice knowing that i worked at
this company and had these resources she
said
you know here's my situation what advice
do you have and her and her husband had
separate accounts
she had a bunch of debt and he had a
bunch of savings
and i was like well we can fix this you
know
i'm just going to connect these two dots
for you and tell you if you combine your
money and actually be a team
as a team you can make so much more
progress you can pull 48 000 pounds as
the analogy
i just think um it it's not just a
marital principle it's a financial
principle yeah yeah whenever two or
three come together so it's like
in this perspective there's two physical
and there's god there's jesus right
there
and it's like i believe we could do a
lot more together and
i just believe that with my personal
walk in faith in your personal walk with
faith that that 50
of marriages can go down we know the
number one cause for
right are divorces it's money right and
so that's our mission is to help people
out with their money so this 50
of divorce rates can go down right and
we're seeing more people
uh married and having a fruitful and
prosperous life
and and i agree that we're going to have
as a merry person there's going to be
some tough seasons
but we shouldn't walk into it saying
it's going to be tough
and more than likely we're going to get
a divorce you know you know so
interesting you just pointed something
out
so as a company ramsey solutions we you
know dave started this 30 years ago
we've been doing this we've seen
millions and millions and millions of
families
become debt free millions and millions
of people change their future we've seen
marriages saved it's incredible
and you know what our advice is not hey
the the secret to a successful marriage
is to have your separate thing going on
to have no it's actually the opposite
it's to put it together
and be a team and it brings a different
sense of unity
to your marriage and to your finances
it's so
so important to be a team yes man listen
to us married people in the world even
single people
uh it's better to be together than to
stand divided
you can accomplish a lot more together
do not listen to this foolishness
don't even read the book smart woman
finish rich no
read the total money makeover get the
business boutique book and we'll help